y'all know that i move with the rare
forest taking flight in the black air
force ones get it done h man y'all know
they heard me rappers like white air
forces cause they flow dirty and scuffed
up hey yo you stepped a hairy mac that's
where you [__] up i can't get enough
stuff they keep hitting me i'm spitting
free y'all know they gon chase this air
force ones i do the laces yeah y'all
must be untied cause y'all trippin it
saves me
delivering division uh i know i'm bout
to represent it proudly i knock them
down like bowling pins i'm the big
lebowski kid y'all know i'm known for my
crushing i get you twisted like you
sipping on the white russians
and y'all know we making them moves and
when it comes to freestyles they know
mac is the dude uh yo i'm making it
happen y'all know i can sue forever the
rug really tied the room together i
can't believe they stole it a little
dicky [__] y'all know i spit these sick
freeze it's me yeah other rappers
sounded too iffy trying to have my own
tv show lil dicky